that led to that extra points on the
clear path
bullock back to randall randall
crossover goes right at drummond and
throws it down
with a foul julius randle with force and
a chance for a three-point play maybe
his ego got involved
looking to block the shot miranda will
hear none of it
as he slams it home
wheels driving on bullock
rebounded by randall rose doing a good
job harassing him on the d
rather nice ball but he slams at home
take a look at this mcconnell he'll
advise the steel attempt
remember what the magic did to the
knicks they double team whom able to
force a jump ball burst
finds randall randall in the corner
harris all over randall step back three
puts it up
shot it's gone it's good randall gets
the bounce
and he ties the game watch randall see
right he has plenty of time to follow
the guy
and watch this folks serendipity
at his best off the glass doc rivers
looked like he was yelling at his team
for not committing the foul there
yeah yeah instead randall gets an
opportunity to shoot
goes high up and then goes through
always no he costs it up ahead to
randall
randall klieba in for sudo and he slams
it down
julius randle with a frustrating night
took it out on that play
wacky now folks for no reason hardaway
just looking
to run the court there's randall
on the turnover by brunson who rarely
turns the ball over
know how dangerous randall was from deep
this season here he is five on the timer
randall puts it on the deck defended on
the play shot
is good and we are tied great driving
kick there for the triple
all the injuries that the hawks had this
season one of the mainstays was harder
look at randall up and under
in this first half young who hurt his
ankle
in the last atlanta game here as randall
goes up high
a little bit of contact no whistle and
sparrow
what's important in situations like this
you can't focus on
your field goal percentage you got to
focus on time and score and that's an
example of
bullock finds randall again gets by
galinari there's cappella though
and now rose for three and he hits it
set up by randall and derrick rose
getting that three cut this lead
and it's down to six points
i love julius randle's article he wrote
in the players tribute
talking about those responsibilities and
he goes hard this time
and scores over capela bogdanovic
starting randall
capela there for help here goes randall
in the lane gives it up gibson oh and a
two-handed jam
taj gibson on the setup from randall
you're the knicks you get randall
downhill
forced to help gibson able to get a
flush down low what a game
knicks lead by seven approaching the one
minute mark with a euro step randall
gets to his strong hand
and finishes makes somebody else catch
and beat and you turn it over
randall gets it off got it at the buzzer
[Applause]
julius randle where he played high
school basketball
working out with drew hanel and his
trainer refining his craft and noella
gets an easy dive
for the bucket 63.
took the words out of my mouth making
good trouble the famous john lewis
statement
and the knicks now starting to make some
shots it feels
like they know how important this game
is atlanta remember they're pretty young
mark
randall with a little bully ball got it
to fall with the offhand
he rebounded from a scoreless game two
at 14 in game three randall
connects on the three guarded by hunter
randall on collins nice pass to gibson
used his body to get the layup yeah he
had to a high
number of 30 foot threes but that aspect
not cooking especially well for him
this game gibson with the quick shot
over capella
on the other end julius gets by has to
put it to taj who goes again innate i
didn't mean to take a victory from you
there my friend
randall on the drive slams at home but
the question
is whether that's too little too late
randall 7 of 19.
you see bullock who's expending a lot of
energy trying to guard trey young c2 go
down
harder lost it bullock off the steal
takes all the way
blocked from behind the final
well if you're struggling offensively
how do you get some easy chippies
on the offensive glass nice follow there
by
randall and this is how you can kind of
get camilo got an arie the one time nick
had a big
game the other day in atlanta
he's checked in for the first time
here's randall able to spin away
the knicks with only one field goal the
last six
and a half minutes as randall
double team gets it to the open man
merlin's no well
able to put it home kept the line by
noel
there's randall around calamari to put
home the reverse
nine in this fourth quarter for young
here's barrett
[Applause]
why are you prolonging the game he's
confused
[Applause]
[Music]